today on the matt wall show the biden
administration has come up with a great
plan to solve the crime epidemic they're
going to give out free crack pipes we'll
discuss also airbnb is now banning
people from its service based on their
political views plus the teachers union
hangs on to masking desperately even as
most everyone else has moved on and
showtime puts out a trailer for the most
absurdly racist documentary ever
produced but it's racist against white
people so you know it's okay we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
so did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
we've all experienced that horrible
feeling whether it's in the back seat of
a car staring at your phone
uh after one too many on a night out
with friends or even just anxiety of a
work day uh we've all been through that
i've been through it myself as as you
know i'm a nausea sufferer i am in that
victim group that community so you've
got to check out relief band relief ben
is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness uh
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy and so much more
how it works is relief band stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain that causes and
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea from patients but now through a
leaf band it is finally available to the
masses plus the product is 100 drug free
it's non-drowsy which is my favorite
thing about it and it provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
relief band makes a great gift for any
time of year right now they've got an
exclusive offer just for my listeners if
you go to reliefband.com and use promo
code walsh you'll receive 20 off plus
free shipping and a no questions asked
30 day money back guarantee that's the
best offer you'll ever find for relief
reliefband anywhere you have to use my
code so head to
reliefband.com and use our promo code
walsh for 20 off plus free shipping
in yet another case of reality becoming
indistinguishable from satire it's being
reported this week that the byte
administration will be using tax money
to distribute crack pipes in the inner
city
or as outlets like the independent and
msn reported gop outraged at biden plan
to fund crack pipe distribution
conservatives pounce
because the story of course is about
biden's ill-tempered critics who are
making such a big deal out of biden
giving out crack pipes the story is not
that you know biden is giving out crack
pipes we're putting in putting the
corporate media spin aside let's let's
look at the details of this plan a plan
which was concocted
it must be noted by a president who
happens to have a crack head for a son
this is perhaps the strangest example of
political nepotism in american history
but the washington free beacon reports
quote the buy administration is set to
fund the distribution of crack pipes to
drug addicts as part of its plan to
advance racial equity the 30 million
grant program which closed applications
on monday and will begin in may will
provide funds to non-profits and local
governments to help make drug use safer
for addicts included in the grant which
is overseen by the department of health
and human services are funds for smoking
kit
supplies a spokesman for the agency told
the washer free beacon that these kits
will provide pipes for users to smoke
crack cocaine crystal meth and any
illicit substance
now apologies ahead of time for letting
you know about this program only after
the application period had already
closed so you'll just have to budget for
crack pipes the old-fashioned way i
guess which uh not this is the main
point at all but
how expensive can crack pipes really be
i mean i i admit i don't know
but but even if it were a good idea to
facilitate the crack habit of crackheads
is this something that they even need i
mean is there any crackhead out there
who really wants to smoke crack but just
can't scrounge together the money for a
pipe
and at any rate if such budgetary
concerns were preventing people from
smoking crack
one might think that that's a good thing
in any case back to the report it says
hhs said the kits aim to reduce the risk
of infection when smoking substances
with glass pipes which can lead to
infections through cuts and sores
applicants for the grants are
prioritized if they treat a majority of
underserved communities including
african americans and lgbtq plus persons
as established under president joe
biden's executive order on advancing
racial equity democratic-run cities such
as san francisco and seattle have
distributed smoking kits to residents
before some local governments however in
recent years backed away from their
smoking kit programs over concerns that
they enable drug use
you think
that's literally the whole point of
the program is to enable drug use hey
wait a second i think this plan to
enable drug use is enabling drug use
it says louisville kentucky for example
allowed convenience stores to sell to
sell smoking kits but later banned them
legislators in maryland ditched their
distribution plan after facing backlash
from local law enforcement and
african-american leaders
okay so so the problem
isn't that crack pipes aren't affordable
it's that back alley crack pipes crack
pipes that you buy on the street might
be dirty and you want to make sure that
we provide
clean crack pipes so that people will
not become sick or get infected
as they inhale poison directly into
their bodies
a little more from the report it says
sergeant clyde boatwright president of
the maryland fraternal order of police
said government resources are better
spent on preventing drug abuse rather
than making it safer quote if we look at
more of a preventive campaign as opposed
to an enabling campaign i think we'll
offer an opportunity to have safer
communities with fewer people who are
dependable uh depending on these
substances
funding for the harm reduction program
is provided through the democratic the
democrats american rescue plan which the
senate passed along party lines after
vice president camille harris cast a
tie-breaking vote other equipment that
qualifies for funding include syringes
vaccinations
disease screenings condoms and fentanyl
strips
the grant program will last three years
and include 25 awards of up to 400 000
um
i mean how do you like that we're we're
lumping the vaccines in with crack pipes
and fentanyl strips
and heroin syringes
i mean you make of that what you will
so a few things jump out at you about
all this
aside from just how utterly and
incomprehensibly insane it is
um the first is that the bite
administration and the leftist regime
generally
do not care about the actual lives of
average americans or americans living in
poor communities or anybody else
now it's not that they actively hate you
because that's something i hear a lot oh
they hate you
um
no i i think that that's it's it's
something even worse than actually it's
just that they don't care
at all
you're a means to an end you as an
individual are irrelevant
and that's why they think nothing of
setting up crack pipe distribution in
neighborhoods whereby the way they don't
live
it's also why they thought nothing of
encouraging and cheering on rioting and
looting
in the places they don't live
they've stopped prosecuting crime in the
places they don't live or if they do
live in these places they make sure that
they have armed security while they
leave everybody else to wallow in the
chaos
human suffering is irrelevant
because what matters first and foremost
of course is their own power and
secondly their ideological dominance and
that's all that matters
second point is that these people have
no understanding of human nature
whatsoever
probably because they care so little for
human beings so they haven't really
stopped to think about the subject of
human nature
and so they say they want to reduce harm
by distributing crack pipes to crack
addicts or or giving out clean needles
to heroin addicts
and the idea is that if people are going
to be doing this stuff anyway then you
might as well make it as safe as
possible but the problem
is that there is no safe way to engage
in a fundamentally destructive activity
you might as well give a suicidal guy a
helmet right before he jumps out of the
30th story window
hey if you're going to kill yourself you
might as well do it safely
because that's what this is i mean
smoking crack using heroin that's this
is a a more drawn out form of suicide
it is absolute total self-destruction
these programs accomplish
because they can't make these activities
safe
or even less harmful to any significant
degree all they accomplish then is to
encourage it
and this is basic human nature which
again the left does not understand
the easier it is to do something
the fewer consequences attached to it
the cheaper it is
the more it is facilitated by other
people
the fewer hurdles we put in the way
the more that people will do that thing
seems pretty simple
to those of us with common sense and who
understand human nature
and third we see again the bigotry of
low expectations except it's not really
low expectations or even no expectations
this is negative expectations
in that the left expects people
especially people in so-called
marginalized groups
to act in abhorrent and self-destructive
ways
in fact they want them to
that's what this is really about
they want them to because it makes them
easier to control and exploit
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
with the ever increasing number of car
makes and models that are on the market
now it's it's impossible to stock all
the parts you need in a traditional
chain storefront why endure then
the pointless or seemingly intimidating
questioning often
about the specifications of your vehicle
only to have the guy behind the counter
order the parts on his computer anyway
why not just cut out the middleman make
it easier on yourself you have you have
computers at home you have computers in
your pocket with access to rockauto.com
so just go right there to rockauto.com
look they're a family business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil and even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
your daily driver get everything you
need in a few easy clips clicks
delivered directly to your door the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands and specifications
and prices that you prefer and of course
as you know the prices are the same for
everyone and uh they're also it's a
great selection and uh low prices for
everyone no matter who you are so go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
write walsh in there how did you hear
about his box so they know that we sent
you
all right so
follow up another follow-up on the joe
rogan story um on tuesday night this is
from the daily wires his iconic
podcaster joe rogan who had the number
one most listened to podcast globally on
spotify 2021 responded on his podcast to
the video compilation of him using the
n-word
saying bluntly this is a political hit
job variety reported quote last friday
spotify pulled 70 episodes of the joe
rogan experience from its platform
dating from 2009 to 2018
which the streamer said it did at the
request of rogan and his team that's
what they claim anyway they claim that
uh joe rogan is the one who decided that
he wants to pull these episodes down and
i don't know if that's true or not i'm
not sure if he's if he has
spoken to that or admitted that it was
his choice or not
but speaking with his guest comedian
akash singh rogen asserted quote in a
lot of ways all this is a relief because
that video had always been out there but
this is a political hit job and so
they're taking all this stuff that i've
ever said that's wrong and they're
smushing it all together but it's good
because it makes me address some things
that i really wish wasn't out there
and then his guest responds you know why
i'm proud of you because i think
comedians have for years done this
immature thing where it's like we don't
apologize we say whatever we want but
you can apologize if you say some wild
stuff
and you apologize and you own it and
that was good for you and then rogan
said you should apologize if you regret
something
this idea that you should never
apologize like if you regret something i
don't think there's anything wrong with
apologizing but i think do think you
have to be very careful not to apologize
for nonsense well
so this is interesting because joe rogan
acknowledges that this is a this was all
a political hit job which of course
is
it was it is
um a highly coordinated and funded
political hit job and there are people
that have looked into the organizations
behind this and there are this is this
is not you know we
as always we hear about clips and things
resurfacing
when there's a compilation video
of every time someone used a bad word
dating back to 2009 i mean we're going
back 13 years
and someone has combed through 13 years
of episodes
and by the way episodes that are long
too i mean each episode is like two or
three hours long
and someone's combed through that and
made a compilation like this that's not
a video that resurfaces it didn't just
bubble to the surface
on its own
and somebody stumbled across it say hey
what's this oh it's joe rogan saying
then the n word a bunch of times
now there's a lot of effort and time
and money that went into finding this
stuff putting it together and then also
getting it out there
distributing it much like the crack
pipes from joe biden
um
so yeah is it a political hit job
absolutely coordinated funded
but then he also says well yeah i i
should it's it's good for me to have
apologized
but what if you know that it's a
political hit job then why would you
apologize
because the question as always
when you say oh i should apologize if i
regret something
my question and the question you should
always keep in mind
before you issue any kind of apology
and this is this is a this is a real
simple question you have to know
who are you apologizing to
who is the aggrieved party
you've been
doing this podcast for 13 years
these are all things that you already
said
if somebody was
personally hurt or damaged by any of
this
then they probably would have already
told you
and if they were if there's someone
personally in your life
who is damaged by something that you do
or say whatever that happens to be
and uh and the you know they tell you
that or and you feel bad about it
um then go ahead and apologize to them
i'm not against apologizing generally
speaking
that's that's like a sociopath if you
say oh i'm never gonna apologize for
anything that i ever do in my life ever
that's not the point
the point is if you cause harm to an
individual
then you seek out that individual and
you apologize to them
because they're the aggrieved party
they're the ones who have been harmed
but the public isn't harmed
what what i i'm a member of the public
i'm
i'm okay
nobody in the public has been harmed
the people who have dug this stuff up
they're not harmed by it
quite the contrary they love it they
think it's great they were looking for
it
they were excited
you know that's that's the irony is that
all the people pretending to be offended
by joe rogan saying the n-word
when they when they heard the video
every single one of them said we got
them they made smiles on their faces
they were gleeful about it
harmed no they they should be they
should be thanking you
because they're so happy about it
so even if you regret it oh you regret
saying it okay
i mean you can you can regret it
but who are you apologizing to
this is apology as performance
for the mob
it's an apology as a you know as a kind
of as a ritual act of of
of humiliation and submission
and that you can't do
and you can't do it because it is a
political hit job
and when you apologize you make it a lot
harder for the next person
okay someone has to draw the line in the
sand
someone has to do it
someone actually has to stand up against
cancel culture and say i'm not going to
apologize i'm not going to play this
game
go ahead and do your worst cancel
culture but you're not going to get
anything out of me
you know you you can play your tune all
you want i'm not gonna dance to it
someone has to do that
and until someone does um this is just
gonna keep happening they're gonna be
more victims and more victims
and the reason why i was disappointed
for joe rogan is because
uh he's he's a even though he seems like
a nice guy it's just
it's disappointing
because he's in a position of such power
got 100 million dollars you're in a 100
million dollar contract
it was a rum rumble the you know the the
youtube alternative came along a couple
days ago and said hey we'll give you 100
million dollars come do your your show
on our platform
so you're sitting you know you are you
are sitting in the in the pilot seat
and you've got all the power here
and when you've got 100 million dollars
like what can they really take from you
and if you're in that position with 100
million dollars and a huge platform and
an enormous audience of millions and
millions of people who will follow you
anywhere you don't really need spotify
you can go you go you could go to rumble
you could go anywhere you could go to
you just make your own website make your
own platform do your own thing entirely
make something that is entirely owned by
you so that nobody can take it from you
start your own subscription service and
there's so much that you can do if
you're joe rogan
and even if you lose some listeners
along the way you lose a bit of money
get a hundred million dollars from your
last contract you're fine
got absolutely nothing to lose
and if you're not going to draw that
line in the sand
sitting there with that much power then
it just makes it so much harder for the
next guy and the next guy is not going
to have all the power that you do
what's frustrating about it
all right next uh you know as more and
more people see the light about masking
still we have especially the teachers
unions who are
holding on to it desperately they don't
want to give it up and here randy
weingarten teachers union boss explains
why you know we might have to keep
masking into the
foreseeable future
the issue becomes how do we make sure
that the entire community in a school
feels safe and welcome and i don't think
that we there's when you get to covid
there's no no risk the real issue
becomes how do we make sure that
everybody feels safe so
if we don't have a mass mandate in
school we gotta make sure that kids and
teachers are not stigmatized for wearing
masks and we better do everything we can
to make sure the ventilation
is
working in um in classrooms so that
there's fresh air and and that we're
doing everything in our power to make
sure that this virus is not
transmissible
well she said there at the very
beginning and and this has been this has
always been obvious that it's about it's
about feelings it's about uh that's what
that's what the masks really are as i've
always said
um
that
the reason why kids are being forced to
mask
it's not for them it's never been for
them
uh because they've never been at any
serious risk from covet
it's not even for the adults physically
it's not to keep the adults safe
it's just to make the adults feel better
and so that's really the trade-off
it is the
the um
it's got nothing to do with physical
well-being for anybody
and even if it was physical well-being
it would still be evil
to sacrifice the psychological
well-being of children for the physical
for the sake of the physical well-being
of adults
that would still be quite an evil thing
but actually the trade-off has been
um we're going to sacrifice the
psychological well-being of children by
forcing them to wear masks every day
they can't see each other's faces they
can't show their own face
um
teaching them that the air is toxic that
everybody around them is toxic and all
that sacrifice their psychological
well-being
for the sake of the psychological
well-being of adults
and not all adults because my
psychological well-being has never been
helped by this
but by the most paranoid
and self-centered
hypochondriac
you know obsessive-compulsive adults
that's the trade-off
that people like randy weingarten have
endorsed this entire time
all right this one the daily wire says
airbnb has banned michelle malkin
blocking the right-wing political
commentator from booking reservations on
its platform
uh and this has finally been by
confirmed by the company
malcolm who has aligned herself in
recent months with nick fuentes is
america first movement said on twitter
wednesday that she and her husband had
been banned from staying at airbnb
locations the vacation rental company
deleted malkin's account because of her
participation in the 2021 american
renaissance conference according to an
email malcolm posted online
the email said it has come to our
attention that you are a keynote speaker
for the 2021 american renaissance
conference earlier this month in
tennessee airbnb's community policies
prohibit people who are members of or
actively associated with known hate
groups
due to your promotion and participation
in a known white nationalist and white
supremacist conference we have
determined that we will remove your
account from
airbnb this is consistent with action
we've taken to ban people associated
with this conference in past years
the platform confirmed uh malkin's ban
in a statement to the daily beast on
wednesday
consistent with our policies
if we become aware of users who are
members of or are actively affiliated
with hate groups we remove them from
airbnb
now
what airbnb has not provided as far as i
know thus far
is
uh
any example
any other example of them doing this
banning someone for being associated
with a quote known hate group
we should also note by the way that
michelle malkin
who's uh being banned from airbnb and
being de-platformed as a white
supremacist is not white
which you would think might be relevant
here
not exactly sure how you can be a white
supremacist when you're not white
but this is um
what one of those things that even
people on the right even now
some of them kind of skimming over
because they say oh well michelle malkin
she's she's too extreme for my tastes
she's uh she's uh getting involved with
nick fuentes and all this and so that's
that's we're not gonna be worried about
that
well you should worry about it for for
reasons of basic self-preservation
this is a definite this is a definite
escalation here
it's a quite a foreseeable escalation
but it's an escalation
because at least
platforms like twitter and youtube and
all that spotify and all the rest of
them um
when they de-platform you for your
opinions
well they can always claim they can
always say that well this is a platform
for
expressing ideas and these ideas that
your that you express are harmful and
dangerous and all and even if that's
nonsense since it's totally bogus they
are at least platforms for expressing
ideas that's why the platforms exist
but airbnb is just a a place where you
rent
vacation homes or if you're going to
stay in an area for a few days and you
you rent out it's that they're not
platforms for the expression of ideas
um as far as i know michelle malkin was
not she wasn't hosting the event
at the airbnb location
she wasn't even having an after party
for everybody afterwards
she was just staying there
and it's not that that airbnb is saying
oh you you can't stay
uh at an airbnb location
while you're attending this event it's
like you can never stay at another
location
because we have decided that your
opinions are unacceptable
oh because they're because you're
associated with a with a hate group
and how do they determine uh what is
what's a hate group will they determine
it based on what groups like the
southern poverty law center
tell them
well the problem is that
the southern poverty law center would
say that all of us are are engaging in
hate speech they would certainly say it
about me and i'm sure they already have
i'm sure they would say if you ask them
that the daily wire is a hate group
that's the uh that's that's the beauty
of that label calling something hate
speech or a hate group
it's so broad and so vague that you can
apply it to anyone
and then when that becomes the pretense
for
um taking away someone's right to access
public accommodations
then you've just opened up floodgates
and that that's what that's what is
happening here
i mean anything can be hate speech
in fact
much of what i engage in
sure
a lot of it is hate speech
i'm talking about things that i hate
like for example
we we started the show talking about joe
biden's
plan to distribute crack pipes
i hate that plan
i am very hateful towards the idea of
giving out crackplate pipes
so is that hate speech i guess
i'm often accused of hate speech when it
comes to the gender issue
sure yeah
a lot of hate speech there too
um i hate gender ideology
i think it's an evil and twisted thing
i hate when kids are being indoctrinated
into it and harmed because of it and
drugged and mutilated i hate that i
really really hate it
so hate speech yeah i guess so
a lot of what i talk about with on the
pro-life issue is is hateful
because i hate the fact that we're
killing
that we've killed 60 million babies
i really hate that i hate the murder of
babies
all of that can be called hate speech i
suppose and the the label is is meant to
be as fluid as that so that it can be
applied to anything and it's completely
subjective
and if now that means you can't access
public accommodations you can't even
stay oh by the way they also stopped her
they also they applied this to her
husband as well not just michelle malkin
her husband guilt by association
her husband cannot stay at airbnb
properties because his wife
has opinions that they don't like
what about her kids
what about her uncles and aunts and
cousins
i guess they're they're next in line
all right here's something that um
i missed last week when i was gone and
um i don't know if you missed it or not
you may have seen it but i've had it on
i i've had it on the the docket here
because
i just it's the kind of thing i have to
comment on professor stephen kirschner
at fredonia university
in an interview
uh here he is that we have a couple
clips we'll play the first one here he
is making the case
for pedophilia listen
imagine that an adult male uh wants to
have sex with a 12 year old girl imagine
that she's a willing participant
a very standard very widely held view
that there's something deeply wrong
about this and it's wrong independent of
it being criminalized
it's not obvious to me that is in fact
wrong i think this is a mistake and i
think that exploring why it's a mistake
will tell us not only things about adult
child sex and statutory rape but also
about fundamental principles of morality
fundamental principles of morality is
worried about uh and it gets worse if
you think that that's as bad as it could
possibly get there are many videos of
this guy which maybe you've seen
floating around there um
this is i hesitate to say that this is
the worst because i haven't watched all
the videos because i can't stomach them
but
this is the worst one that i could
stomach watching listen to what he says
here
there's a couple things to say here one
is even if you are looking for a
threshold let's say there's a threshold
i'm making this number up but let's say
it's at age eight
um
still that tells you that some adult
child sex is permissible
second the notion that it's wrong even
with a one-year-old
it's not quite obvious to me there are
reports and some cultures of
grandmothers fellating their uh the baby
boys to calm them down when a colicky
now i don't know if this is true but
this is sort of widely reported as
occurring in in at least one culture and
it working that the grandmothers believe
i believe this actually works
if this were to be true and again i
don't know it to be true if it were to
be true it's hard to see what would be
wrong with it
so yeah i guess i think no i don't think
there's a blanket
period beyond which this is permissible
if we're interested in willing
participation which is the way i
structured it then yeah there's a
there's a point below which people
aren't willing to dispense in anything
because they don't have intentions or
they don't have the sort of mental
states that allow for willing
participation
but no i don't i don't think it's
blanket wrong at any age
this is a college professor um
philosophy professor
and he says that it's
at no age is it necessarily wrong well
going all the way down to
one
as you just heard him say
um
hopefully most people
at least most rational people can see
now
that it's not a slippery slope
um there there is in effort in
increasing effort
by people and it always starts in
academia
so we have it now in academia we've seen
it elsewhere but this is not the first
college professor we've heard in the
last couple of months
talking about normalizing pedophilia
and and hopefully it's obvious by now
this is not a some slippery slope
conspiracy this is this is
uh it is a slippery slope but it's real
and we're on it
and normalizing pedophilia is sort of
the last
that's the last barrier to come down
and it's going to calm down because all
the rest have
you know now it's now it's a matter of
pure ideological momentum
and we also know what's going to happen
for a couple other reasons one is that
as i've pointed out many times
you know
everything that's happening with gender
is setting the stage for the
normalization of and you know eventually
the legalization of pedophilia
because the whole the whole you know
this professor of course waves away this
uh this
logic
but one of the reasons
why pedophilia is a is a hideous evil
is that children cannot consent they
can't they they don't have the
psychological
capacity they don't have the mental
faculties all in place to actually
consent to do something like that
they their their brains are not fully
formed yet
and so they can't possibly know
what they're doing
and also the power dynamics and
everything else between an adult and a
child so
the child can't consent to it
but
if you're arguing that a child can
consent
at the age of uh 12
to chemical castration
um
because a boy wants to become a girl
that a 14 year old girl can consent to
ever breast chopped off
permanent life-altering decision
or even that a three-year-old can
make it make the decision to start
transitioning their gender
if if that's the argument that you're
making
that almost everybody on the left makes
not just kooky college professors way
out on the fringes
if that's the argument that you're
making then you have already started to
tear down this last barrier
by by claiming that children can consent
to life-altering decisions to
life-altering sexual decisions
so this is uh quite inevitable
and here's the latest on this from the
local abc affiliate in buffalo it says
the fredonia professor who you just
heard there is being assigned to duties
that do not include his physical
presence on campus and will not have
contact with students as an
investigation continues following his ca
his comments on adult child sex
um
the the fredonia
released a response as soon as these
videos came out and the response from
the statement from president stephen h
collison
says fredonia is aware of a video posted
online involving one of its professors
the views expressed by the professor are
reprehensible and do not represent the
values of fredonia in any way shape or
form they are solely the professor's
views the matter is being reviewed
oh so they're gonna they're gonna review
it they're investigating it but he's
still getting paid
and he still has a job
and my prediction is that you know
within a few weeks he's gonna be back on
the job they're waiting for the heat to
to get off of them because this is not
by the way this is not a surprise to
them
this guy has been talking about this
issue
and uh he's been on this train of of uh
normalizing and legalizing and
justifying validating pedophilia for
years
they knew that he thought all of this
they even knew he was out doing
interviews about it
they just didn't expect it would go
viral and that uh the wrong people would
see it so they're waiting for the heat
to come off and then they're gonna i
guarantee
put them back on assignment all right uh
final thing here's a cnn report about
moms who come together in a parking lot
every once in a while
to uh to scream not exactly sure why but
let's watch and find out
when at first
you're
you're a little nervous right or a
little like can i do this is this is
this appropriate
you feel lighter
you feel
a complete release
you feel it's it's nice to feel out of
control
you want a chatter buddy
back in 2020 when we went into pandemic
quarantine for the first time
i went instantly went remote with all my
clients and started having conversation
after conversation about the struggles
that
women and moms were having one place
i also have two little kids so i was
living what they were talking about we
were stuck at home we couldn't see the
people that helped us even therapy
sessions were via zoom i could feel
their anger through the screen i could
sense it in my own body connecting to
theirs and i would say to them
we just need to go into a field and
scream
that was where it started and then a
year later when we were still stuck in
this pandemic still experiencing a lot
of the
same overwhelm we did it again
in january of 2022
okay well if you thought that liberal
women couldn't get any more annoying
you stand corrected
i have an idea how about you just uh you
just suck it up buttercup
how's that for an idea
control your emotions a little bit
oh we're so we're so stressed we have to
go out into the parking lot and scream
let everybody know it
what what what happened to just
you know i don't know being an adult
having a little bit of maturity
this this is this is how like this is
how my
my
two-year-old handles her stress
a little bit of maturity that's my idea
just a thought let's get down to the
comment section
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
all right we'll start with our uh
brand spanking new video comments let's
begin let's play uh clip eight first
hey matt this is joshua royal wathen i
am the proud author of the sweet baby
gang anthem with all the fun being had
in the video comments i wanted to submit
one from myself with a new verse that i
wrote just for you take a
listen virginia
who's bringing shopping carts back to
the rightful place
[Music]
let me know what you think of it if you
like it i'll create an official extended
version and release it on spotify uh or
if not just cancel me that's fine too uh
regardless man thank you so much for
what you do and for allowing me to be a
part of your show in this way
it's beautiful josh i really it almost
if i if i could experience human emotion
i would have i think i probably would
have cried
uh
and joshua royall is the poet laureate
of the of the sweet baby gang
uh i i think that's the best i think we
need to take that verse
and make that the verse that we play
before the comment that's my that's my
and we gotta that's the verse right
there
as good as the verse is that we use
i think that's it
wonderful beautiful
um
what else is there to say
let's go to uh let's play clip this is a
long one uh clip six
hey matt my name is jeff
with all this talk about voting going on
the last couple of weeks i wondered what
you would make of a system of weighted
voting not sure if any countries do this
but i like the idea of a system that has
maybe up to 10 points
you get one when you come of age another
point when you turn 40 another when
you're 60 those ages could be tweaked
depending um three more points for
taking a series of tests optional
i would do economics u.s law u.s history
world history and current world affairs
you could choose any one of those up to
three get up to three points and these
are hard tests i would i would make them
you know you sit for an hour maybe two
100 multiple choice questions so you
really have to know your stuff
the final four points i would give to
having dependents being a property owner
being a business owner and serving in
the military in some capacity and you
could argue about how many years of
service or
um how many dependents how big your
business has to be but you know that's
the general framework and then there's a
lot you could do with this system you
could
knock felons back down to one point so
they still get to vote but it's not
worth as much and i like this because
even your average citizen who
starts a family buys a house starts a
business takes their test is gonna have
a vote that's worth eight nine or ten
and people that just don't care all that
much are just going to be stuck at a one
or two so it really
drives home the fact that you know
stakeholders and people with skin in the
game
that put in the effort are gonna have
more of a say in how our countries run
uh very curious what you'd have to say
about that spg for life thank you
well it's it's a better system than what
we have right now um but then again
pretty much any system is better i think
when it comes to any voting system is
better than we have right now
where everyone is allowed to vote no
matter how
ignorant
uninformed they happen to be
and their vote counts exactly the same
as uh as someone who actually knows what
they're doing and is paying attention
and at least knows what universe and
what galaxy and what country they're
living in
so anything's better than that i think
that that is an improvement
um
it's a creative idea i'll give you that
i've never heard that that concept
before
so i like that we're having this
conversation like at least this is a
conversation we should we should
actually be having on a national level
so i like that my only problem with it
is that number one you get it gives too
much weight
to age
so there's i don't see any reason why
say a sick someone who's 60 their vote
should count more than someone who's 30.
i am a proponent of raising the voting
age
above 18
only because 18 year olds are still
kids really
i mean effectively you're still a kid
and your brain isn't isn't even fully
developed yet until you're like 25
which is why i think you can make the
argument for putting the voting age at
25.
but then once you're fully an adult
and especially if you are
especially if you're an adult and you're
married and you have a family
and you have a job and all that and
you're a taxpayer
um i don't see any reason why you would
gain more
credit just just simply by getting older
so that's one problem the other problem
is you know you're still talking about
giving some kind of vote to people who
have no skin in the game and have no
idea what they're doing
and my point is that their vote should
count for zero they should have zero
points they should have zero say
if you have no skin in the game you're
not invested at all
um
and uh and you and you don't know
anything about the system you're
participating in
then you should get no vote at all
but again it's a good conversation
uh
let's see this is from
officer derek chauvin i'm guessing not
the one and only says it's stunning and
brave that these woke warriors would
take their masks off and risk covid to
infiltrate the sbg crowd yeah we'll see
we'll see how many show up today i'm
speaking at texas a m tonight at uh
seven o'clock and we talked yesterday
about their the leftist plan to
infiltrate
and we'll see they got to get 35. that's
their that's what they wrote down on
their little uh
on their little chart they got to get 35
and if they can't get 35 they're all
gonna walk away so we'll see
um contextually obligated says i
normally love matt's parenting advice
but this one stressed me out as a new
mom she's one years old now
so maybe i'm just paranoid but i can't
leave my daughter alone in the car for
even a split second i'm afraid i'd have
a heart attack or spontaneously combust
before i get back to the car and she'll
just sit in the back
and cook and no one would know that
she's back there i do struggle but i
bring the cart back with her and my arms
as long as you're returning the cart
but this is one of those things you know
one of those
areas of kind of absurd paranoia in our
culture
like yes obviously if it's 100 degrees
outside uh you're not going to leave
your kid in the car for
any extended length of time because
that's extremely dangerous and you're
going to kill them but that so that's
that's clear it should be clear that you
shouldn't be doing that
but in a lot of cases that's now morphed
into
if it's 65 degrees out
you can't leave your kid in a locked car
for
a minute to go return a shopping cart or
even like
just run into the gas station real quick
and buy something come on
that doesn't make any sense it's that's
paranoia there's really nothing behind
it and
uh but i also understand if she's one
and you're a new parent you're gonna be
paranoid i get it
um
look and who am i to talk about paranoia
i still before i go to bed each night i
go upstairs and i check all my kids to
make sure they're still breathing and i
still do that and my our oldest are
eight years old so
uh and finally this guy's the limit says
dear mats protesters if you really want
to blend in head to the dw store and
pick up a few spg and johnny the walrus
shirts and a few copies of the book
helps to bring a leftist tears tumbler
or two that's a great idea you know i
suggested and i i gave the the hint that
if you want to be heterosexual passing
as they said they want to be so they can
blend in with the crowd they can wear
t-shirts that say i'm heterosexual
because of course that's what all
cisgender heterosexual people do
even better though and i'm ashamed i
didn't think of this is that's right
go to dailywire.com shop go to our store
buy all the matt walsh merchandise and
then you'll blend in
and i'll get paid also at the same time
so
kill two birds with one stone well the
day is almost here tomorrow february
10th will be the world premiere of
shut-in daily wire's first original film
at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central over at
daily wire youtube the suspenseful
thriller follows a young mother trapped
by her violent ex and his meth addicted
friend and she must escape to save her
children before it's too late it's a
tale of redemption to the beat of a seat
gripping thriller and i must say it's a
phenomenal piece of film as well check
out the trailer
[Music]
so sorry
[Music]
is
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what good is this doing now
i'm scared
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
the film premieres this thursday
february 10th at 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central over daily wire youtube after
this month's episode of backstage so
make sure you click the link in the
description and turn on the notification
bell so you don't miss it because after
the premiere it's only available to
daily wire members and if you're not a
member head to dailywire.com subscribe
and enter code shut in for 30 off your
membership now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know there's always been racism in
the world and there always will be
contrary to the convenient ad hoc
arbitrary definition the left gives the
word today racism is simply the hatred
toward or resentment of another group of
people based on their skin color racism
is it's not a single word somebody says
it's not a joke they make racism also is
not dependent on power structures or
systems or institutions
any old schlub can be a racist
and the racism of the least powerful is
no more justified than the racism of the
most powerful
racism is not the exclusive domain of
domain of one race or another
no race has a monopoly on racism either
as victim or perpetrator
and racism is not necessarily
a crisis because if somebody is racist
and their racism is largely rejected by
the society they live in
then there's not a whole lot of harm
that his racist thoughts can do
his racism is likely to remain mostly in
his thoughts
because it's not accepted by society
where it damages him more than it
damages anybody else
where racism becomes truly dangerous is
where it's accepted by the culture
racism that society embraces even
celebrates is the kind it's the only
kind that can cause widespread harm it's
the only kind that we really have to
worry about but given that society
accepts
this kind of racism most people in
society are not worried about it which
means always that the kind of racism
everyone should worry about
is by definition exactly the kind that
they're not worrying about
and in our culture of course that is
anti-white racism
it is only in a country that embraces
and celebrates anti-white racism that
something like this can exist according
to the film website collider filmmaker
sasha jenkins has teamed up with
showtime to shine a light on
institutionalized and systemic racism
and a new docu-series titled
everything's going to be all white
in the series trailer viewers hear from
multiple people of color speaking about
their experiences with racism and the
negative impact of whiteness in america
set to debut debut on february 11th the
three-part limited series will feature
interviews with historians artists
activists cultural commentators actors
and more
in a trailer that gives a may trigger
white people disclaimer at its start
several interviewees provide their
commentary on everything from white
fragility to the capital rise of january
2021 through facts historical events and
even some comedy the trailer focuses its
lens on the problematic systems that are
in place to hold people of color down
while elevating caucasians
well this sounds bad already you don't
know the half of it the trailer for this
thing came out a few days ago
and it is maybe the most unabashedly
gleefully racist thing
you'll ever watch in your life take a
look
[Music]
i think what annoys me most about white
people is when they pretend like they're
the victim
what's also annoying is when they you
know when they kill us
we'll just stop there for a second to
note that it is it is certainly annoying
to be killed i i agree with you there
but it's very rare
that a white person kills a black person
it's also comparatively rare that a
black person kills a white person white
people tend to kill white people and
black people tend to kill black people
black people make up a hugely
disproportionate number of murder
victims but they're almost all killed by
other black people and as for
interracial murder which again is rare
more whites are killed by black people
than black people by white people
those are the facts
in case they matter to you
back to the trailer
what is fragile about whiteness when
everything has been constructed around
it
every part of who i am has been
distorted or criminalized it's really
just a bunch of white lies
you know fragility is an interesting
concept
let me ask you this
when white people
are told that there's a certain word
they can't say in any context
they can't even utter the syllables no
matter the reason or intention
because of the harm that word will do to
members of the of another race
where is the fragility there who's being
fragile
when a black nfl coach cries that he's
being oppressed because it took him more
than three hours to find a new coaching
job
is that fragility
see as it turns out there's quite a lot
of fragility in our culture
but but it's not that one race or
another is fragile
there is in fact plenty of fragility
among white people too it's that it's
that fragility is cultivated
among members of victim classes
they are treated as fragile
encouraged to be fragile
encouraged to be helpless to be victims
that's where the fragility is
all right let's go back to the trailer
you're not patriots you're ridiculous
one of the definitions of american
whiteness is
ignorance
white people we are not your problem
you are should white people today feel
any responsibility for slavery
hell yeah
white jesus or black jesus jesus was not
white think of geography ain't no way
jesus walked around with blonde hair and
blue eyes
white culture fears the end of the world
for us as native people the end of the
world already happened like multiple
times
[Music]
symbols and monuments these are mementos
of racism bring that statue that
what about tcby yogurt or something
everybody can get behind
the truth has to be told about history
we have to make sure that these stories
are told from our perspective
all right i think it's probably about
enough of that you know i often hear
just on this on this jesus white jesus
thing i i often hear it insisted that
jesus isn't white
um but the interesting thing is i never
hear anyone insisting that he is white
so race hustlers love to go on and on
about the fact that jesus didn't have
blonde hair and blue eyes which is a bit
like me running around telling everybody
that george washington wasn't a black
guy from nigeria it's true of course
that george washington wasn't african
but by debunking that idea i'm debunking
something that i made up in my head in
the first place in a similar way nobody
ever said that jesus looked like he's
from sweden
now you might see jesus depicted with
lighter skin in some art but that's
because
nobody knows what jesus looked like
and so it's physical depictions which
are all essentially fictional
because there's no portrait provided to
us in the bible
so people are kind of making it up
that means his physical depictions are
going to reflect the people who create
the depiction
black artists will probably tend to make
jesus look a little bit blacker while
white artists may tend to make him look
a little bit whiter
now jesus i can assure you is not
offended by any of this
in fact jesus doesn't really care if we
get his physical description exactly
right
and i feel comfortable speaking for
jesus on this point
and i know that he doesn't care because
if he did
he would have provided us with that
description
instead of leaving it so conspicuously
absent from the record
and so what that means is that people
again sort of make it up
and as artists
it's going to reflect their you know
it's kind of reflect themselves in a
certain way that's fine
not a problem
now you notice at the end of the clip
we're told that the stories of history
including the gospel story i guess
must be told from our perspective
meaning the non-white perspective
of course anyone who tells a story is
going to be telling it from their own
perspective nobody is suggesting that
black people shouldn't have a
perspective or they shouldn't tell
stories grounded in that perspective but
what he really means what this
documentary along with critical race
theory as a whole is trying to get
across
is that the stories of history and the
story of america and the story of our
culture both past and press and present
must be told from a perspective that is
actively antagonistic towards white
people
that's what's really meant
now think about this
is there any country in the non-western
world
where the culture is openly antagonistic
to the nation's predominant race
could something analogous to what i just
played for you
exist in any non-western country
you know something like that targeting
the majority of the people in the
country
on racial grounds
could there be any serious movement
anywhere else
to shame and demonize and exclude and
marginalize the majority race in the
country
has anything like this ever existed
anywhere in history
i think not
and it's gotten to this point now
through years of conditioning
not only the conditioning of non-white
groups to hate white people and blame
them for every problem
even and especially the problems that
members of these other groups
largely cause through their own choices
but on top of that there has to have
been a long and sustained effort to
condition white people to hate
themselves hate who they are
loathe their own identity
it's probably not a coincidence this is
all happening at the same time that
gender ideology takes hold
because all of this comes down to a
hatred and rejection
of yourself
that's the only way that any of this
stuff can happen
that's how we end up with that
the most ridiculously racist
thing
put on film in
decades easily
and you can watch it on showtime
this week
which is why today we must say that
showtime is canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
[Music]
so sorry
now
is
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what good is this doing now
i'm scared
no
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
laughs
[Music]